( intro music )
The next story that I proposed
was, you know, photographing
one of the most pristine
places in the Indian Ocean.
It's this tiny atoll
called Bassas da India.
This is all there is at
high tide. That is it!
And it's this incredible place,
it's in the cyclone belt
and of course, since you
can't see it at high tide
there are shipwrecks everywhere.
And you know, the outer
perimeter creates
this almost
bathtub-like lagoon.
And this is a nursery ground
for Galapagos Sharks.
Sharks and healthy reefs
kind of go together
because the sharks govern
the ratio of reef fish
of algae, of sea urchins
and all those things.
So, sharks are critical
for healthy coral reefs.
And these reefs were in
incredible condition.
They're curious.
( audience laughter )
They are very, very curious.
I've always known
Galapagos Sharks
as being very, very
night active.
So, I also wanted to
photograph them at night
and this is inside the lagoon
on one of the coral reefs.
And, one of the most magical,
you know, two hours of my life
just watching these sharks,
like,
you know,
moths to a flame.
They're just kind of swimming
in and swimming out.
These images and this
experience really just
you know,
gave me hope again that
even though we've impacted
our oceans in so many places
every time you get sort
of, despair overcomes you
mother nature kinda taps you
on your shoulder and goes
"I'm still around, you
just have to go there."
And this is one of those places,
etched into my memory forever.
Bassa da India in Europa Atoll.